it's too dangerous I have to go alone
these are the words Daisy Ridley's Rae
utters in the brand-new footage from
Star Wars the rise of Skywalker shown at
2019 s d23 Expo Lucasfilm took the stage
on Saturday during the hotly anticipated
Walt Disney Studios presentation to
unveil fresh footage from the Star Wars
saga ending the rise of Skywalker
director JJ Abrams explained that the
creative team is working hard on putting
the finishing touches on the pill and is
tinkering away on a new trailer to
reveal ahead of the movie's December
20th release date but it didn't want to
leave the Star Wars fans and attendants
hanging so he his Lucasfilm partners and
the rise of Skywalker cast gifted the
world with a stellar sizzle reel
featuring shots from the play the
footage reportedly received the standing
ovation The Hollywood Reporter had the
breakdown of the footage which shows the
sizeable fleet of stardestroyers
clustered in the sky Rey and kylo Ren
battling in top a sunken ship in the
ocean and a first look at Keri Russell's
character Zuri bliss in action a Boba
Fett style bounty hunter type whom
Russell describes as quote very cool and
a little bit shady kind of a criminal
she's also apparently an old friend of
Poe dameron's the new rise of skywalker
footage ended with the most jaw-dropping
shot of all rheya scene cloaked in a
dark hood and holding a dual bladed
lightsaber that's glowing red lightsaber
it belongs to me this suggests that Rey
who struggled with understanding and
channeling the force and the last Jedi
may give in to temptation and turn to
the dark side in the rise of Skywalker
come on a red saber with two blades of
black hood over her head Ray's giving
some serious Darkseid vibes in the new
footage and it's already sending fans
into a spiral of speculation with many
theorizing that the get up she sports in
the new footage may be her response to
discovering her true parentage which has
always been a hot point of discussion
amongst fans if the rise of Skywalker
reveals that Rey is a descendant of a
prominent dark Sider like say Emperor
Palpatine she certainly couldn't be
blamed for having an existential crisis
on the other hand maybe she's wearing a
creepy hood and wielding a new
lightsaber because she's trying to
infiltrate the first order as part of a
resistance mission that seems more
likely than Rey going mad but hey
anything goes in the Star Wars universe
unfortunately the rise of Skywalker
sizzle reel wasn't immediately made
available online the silver lining is
that something else related to the movie
is a badass new poster Lucasfilm
unveiled the one
she to the Walt Disney Studios
presentation on Saturday giving fans a
glimpse at the tone and aesthetic of the
upcoming film aside from Palpatine's
telltale cackling the first rise of
Scott Walker teaser it's one of the
first confirmations that the one-time
Emperor of the galaxy will be playing a
role in Episode nine
these reveals should tide fans over
until Lucasfilm drops the second trailer
for the rise of Skywalker and definitely
served a boost height for the flick that
will supposedly cap off the nine movie
Skywalker saga the Star Wars franchise
will of course live on after the rise of
Skywalker with new movies from last Jedi
director Rian Johnson and Game of
Thrones creators David Benioff and DB
Weiss there's also the three live-action
Star Wars TV series coming to the Disney
Plus streaming platform the Mandalorian
a rogue one prequel centered on diego
luna's character Cassie and and/or and
the recently announced obi-wan Kenobi
show hello that still the rise of
Skywalker marks the end of an important
era and will apparently be the last Star
Wars film for a while as the franchise
has taken a hiatus from feature films
after its release the hope is that the
rise of Skywalker will be so epic that
fans completely forget there won't be a
new Star Wars movie hitting the big
screen for some time based on this
footage description the new poster and
the action-packed first trailer that
goal should be easily achieved the end
is nigh and the saga is sure to go out
with a bang when episode 9 lands in
theaters on December 20th check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]